you
all right we are set to go this one has
the title tricky Knights arena and round
one the start of this there are 36 in
this created tournament have
Scandinavian on board and let's see what
that Queen is up to she going to go
anywhere
uh-huh so I have the g5 square let's
jump in there east six is pretty
sensitive I like the idea of going Queen
side gonna give me the bishop pair not
so fast
who I'm going to sacrifice right here
hmm very interesting yeah good move man
I was lining up something here I don't
think I could take that so yeah now my
bishop can maybe be a problem
threatening a trap okay let's start with
this I want to take that pawn
okay officially don't have anything well
clock in the bishop pair but that's
about it
yeah it's just a clock lead the usual
case and straw pins in there all right
clock oh man i stunk tied there uh yeah
I just have a fast mouse it wasn't uh
wasn't good that was I was a killer I'm
not a killer shop but how to describe it
the if I took that rook I was going to
have to be facing a discovered check and
I'd lose my queen so uh okay like I want
to do this in between err gain a
valuable temple against the Queen if I
did this one move sooner there would
just be Queen here at least my knight is
protected
I had the bishop pair and I have this
square to work with some good
development keep pieces off of g5 and
maybe throw this pawn down break down
their Queen side a hat made on g2 ah
just one moment I had one moment for
Queen takes g2 hmm let me get me the
back rank not quite how do I make
progress that's a check let's do this
Queen's gonna have to block or the
bishop mmm just got a free rook this one
would have been a bad one to lose Oh
missing out on maintenance it's no good
we're just central with our queen rut
material let's trade take your next hit
it f2 Queen esta
walk or mate back to termit that one
could have been over so much sooner
those are precious seconds precious
minutes
all right we got five up top here when
we got Popovic
all righty let's try a Kings Indian oh
that was a quick investment of the
bishop pair we're going to keep the d6
pawn around I'm not going to castle
I like anchoring my knight here and
maybe I was a bit too quick with my dark
square Bishop Bishop h6 converging on
this squares let's actually go back here
maybe I do without castling put the fear
in white going to take my knight yep
already oh that Knight is kind of in the
way of the king now King can't go to g2
okay let's break down these squares got
a check that's me Wow now the King has
to go back need my rook to help I could
have also captured here let's pin that
night get some material our knight is
pinned there's so much for
attack yeah
abort got abort that one uh-huh it's
kind of scary time clean trade would be
nice all right should be able to pull
this one off clockwise do sneaky stuff
turn
time time time we caught the big blue up
there at eight eight I should look to
win games objectively once in a while at
least ah 22 minutes still plenty of time
49 are in this one alright we're going
to call this guy Nick
I guess Nick is here let's do F for 9 f3
ah they moved I didn't see it
alright let's tuck this Bishop back and
look to drift towards their Kings side
I'm looking for f5 not with the idea to
recapture just as a clearance and this
pawn is pinned and now they're staring
at some issues here making two ideas
take the bishop and then take here the
night I could just take and it should be
a pretty devastating attack okay
going to run let's see how far he gets
well it's probably a time when let's
start with the check get this knight
involved he's running away I guess we'll
go here yeah
and now the checks kind of run out don't
they I have this move okay I got the
Queen let's come back and I just want to
get at the King still should I still be
going for that they're threatening a
fork I don't know here then I could take
it just looking for trades actually
there's a fork there anything there down
on time
yeah they had to chew on a lot of stuff
there's a lot to calculate they're
easily collapse the King side the rook
the bishop and the light square bishop
playing dark square Bishop King rook was
in on the attack the Queen of course got
15 up top Ronda is in the number one
spot with 15 and he has fire alright
let's go with an advanced French and I'm
gonna play it where I just give that
pawn up okay I was okay with actually
just them capturing okay let's
drift over to g3 they really want to
pinpoint that off pawn I guess night on
g3 okay Bishop here now dropping my beep
on Queen h5 stuff ooh this is calling
out crying out to be played over there's
Queen takes f2 I didn't even realize
it's nothing serious though King h2 is
fine but I didn't even consider it it's
just me - all right back to tournament
all right we have twit okay
as a quick pairing 2016 16 is where I'm
at and number three spot Ally Ekans
defense okay see if they Castle are they
going to Castle I'm lining up a trick on
h7 I want to go Queen side okay still
want to go clean side yeah gain the
tempo against the Queen Bishop here mmm
dropping the H pun Wow
very very greedy very greedy what's that
even do oh I didn't see that their queen
was hit they could have done it like a
capture could have done many things I
just want trays I could care less about
my structure here so let's see if they
take my queen will turn into pac-man
soon enough I have a knight check the
bishops close to trapped now you know
take them out
then I'm uh-oh I have that move oops
alright let's run it like this clean
here hits everything let's take King
takes
where are the pawns it's my move I
didn't see that they moved now they have
some coordination now let's not do a pre
move about we go over here and then
break down their structure now we got
this fork for a second I thought that
they were able to maybe block with the
rook not the case 24 2016 is where we're
at we still have 16 minutes and change
in this one now 56 56 enters entries
enters all right I feel like I want to
try something else
opening wise I guess we'll take pretty
simple setup here for black very logical
type moves good lineup
battery towards their king now that
they've weakened this dark square with
h3 now there's some restriction placed
on those pieces Knight takes is a
blunder I believe because a bishop takes
here threatening to take take and then
made on each - I could do that let's
take your first and there and here and
not take that pawn because he's poison
so after the smoke clears I'm just down
I can't break down the Queen side so
well I'm going to give that pawn up now
take here hmm yeah this is scary no they
gave me that pawn yeah this was
definitely helpful all right let's take
him out hmm
I shouldn't have been able to weasel out
of that so easily okay my queen needs to
help I still need a flight square and a
flight square in there no why would you
make that move my Kings over to stop
this pawn all right
they started pre moving too soon think
oh I got to get that off back determine
preferences game behavior always promote
to a queen okay um Ron DAP head doesn't
have fire so his last game was a draw
he's he's in another one though I'm two
points back around out alright maybe I
shouldn't have counseled so soon might
try for the z5 stuff now let's get
developed Queen Bishop needs to play
let's keep this tension I don't think
either of us do well to release it and I
know here maybe should have done this
move sooner soon as that night left
should have jumped right in now it's
really effective because I'm winning
upon and I'll be attacking the Queen
let's get him out of here oh wow okay I
have this move take the Queen's and the
knight moves maybe there's stuff here on
the e2 square have the bishops now and a
pawn and let's just continue expanding
hmm
take spawn is there nice shot uh-huh Wow
okay there's a night move with the
discovery let's take care and their time
edge and I could have taken that beep on
why didn't I do that let's kick the
night away he's not bothering me there
let's get pushing this guy he's passed
keep going he was free there down in
time back to tournament 28 have a lead
Ronde up slipped up his last game he's
back in another one against queen master
77 28:28 I'm tied with ok this guy I
guess he just finished probably get
paired up yes so this is the number 2
guy there's 12 minutes left
throw the Sicilian atom this is our
sixth game played before
ok and go b6 maybe b5 is better huh I
don't know you know b5 is better clear
loss of time right there let's Castle
incoming g5 it's not exchange get Knight
g3 sack huh yeah scary I have that
square covered my knight is a bit off
side there Oh
not expecting that
Queen Queen takes here with check I
don't know let's open it up in the
center take here if Knight takes here I
guess
I have to stop Queen here pretty scary
on my night on f5 on the bishop let's
take the Queen starting to consolidate
now and knights in a pin let's keep them
there let's take them out he's too
tricky let's take him out that's so fast
14 seconds where's my king going do I
not realize he needs to be over here can
I
that game I don't know six seconds have
any time oh you bugger uh any time I'm
down in time oh oh he's got a lead now
clearly we're under ten minutes
he's got fire he won that last one he
was drew maybe by mistake I don't know
32:29 where did I spend all my time
thinking in that one ah well he did have
some pressure with that sacrifice and to
be very delicate with where to put my
queen so I was probably chewing on a lot
of seconds there all right
let's challenge their on duo get to the
C file I gotta get that guy back he's
still with it says withdrawn huh I
wonder what the story is with that take
here mmm
let's open my bishop sighs maybe look
for efore next they have a majority that
they're trying to get going stop that
idea let's break in the center no I
guess here yeah they're gonna have
strong queen position in the center hmm
Bishop takes g7 is a threat even if the
Queen was still there defending so
that's a that's a big big pawn I'm gonna
get rook g5 and I want to keep these
pieces on King is a bit more vulnerable
let's take him out actually I had Queen
here one move sooner that's winning this
rook and they resigned back determine
36:31 he's still withdrawn huh okay 36
31 I'm at 30 hmm okay um six points back
from the top guy but really just one
back if he's not going to jump back in
he could he will most likely be caught
only takes a couple games so kick this
night away and Wow
okay we're going to
to f6 and then sneak into these dark
squares and we're getting in there its
mate next no matter what well unless the
Queen gives a check back determine 36 32
31 he's back in he's back in he's live
six minutes and change 63 players in
this one
Kovac all right let's try e4 and we're
going to look to grab some space here
with this guy oh my goodness can you
move okay
secure b4 okay let's go caveman style
some play f5 really weakens these light
squares I'm just looking to break them
down with h5 if they had v4 there'd be
some problems got to take with the F
pawn I guess taking like that
alright gonna take off too
I guess huh I have this square covered
okay there's that as a lucky find
I'll look what I found move fork on that
a bunch and we're up a piece and I'm
still looking for me even though the
Queen's aren't on the board all right I
got to take with the F pawn now
push the h pon I'm looking for g4 we got
mate next on h8 back to term at the
knight and Bishop coordinate really well
okay this guy's withdrawn again but he's
up to 40 now maybe he's picking and
choosing when he wants to play okay we
are paired up again okay so he's well
aware of fishing pole ideas and we're
going to go straight in for B 5 and B 4
gonna counsel you know let's get that
move in there
yeah let's let's do this Knight B 5 now
why'd I do that
the bad idea very very bad idea my night
is trapped now yikes
I have this move my night is a bit silly
though oh they have a night move and
then there was a an issue there I
thought okay you got to get some faster
moves in not playing this well I have
the two bishops okay I have the f5
square mmm man is this scary need some
breathing space for my king we have 20
seconds okay
that move and see that okay how this
works um they're gonna hit me with the
fork I'm still in this pickle oh no I
got to keep a piece around I just
dropped it they had Knight takes rook
I have we're tied there's time for one
more game roundup is right on my heels
40 40 39 29 oh my goodness
ugliness I don't know what this rook g8
idea is about okay this is probably the
last game I got to get this one in and I
think I'll have it
okay let's pinpoint the c4 pawn and
still have that ID in mind
I have a night move to be four let's
throw some strikes the night is now
pinned I like giving me that and I'm
winning the night I'm up a piece the
knight is pinned just want to trade take
here if f4 let's box the night out doing
all right on the clock just want to make
sure this game could finish I just drop
my knight
okay
54 seconds on the game clock my opponent
has 23 seconds missed anything on the
Queen they missed that they might resign
45 seconds I'm going to resign they're
not resigning got a watch I don't get
known a fried I got to do time burners
okay getting mate soon 9 seconds I could
have just captured that push up 22
seconds we got me back to tournament oh
by a point is this game over with no he
got another game in ah man that came
just finished I guess he has 47 a
buzzer-beater ah man I thought I had it
Ron deaf man
snuck that one right in there all right
that was close that was good
64 players in this one roundup taking
first with 47 I was in second 42 VIN VIN
the one who nicked me had 40 and then
coup queen master slim mg
coming in with fourth place Bogdan
Povich Ruffo the big blue promote King
and who else
let's see page two three four six seven
all right I had fourteen and Rhonda pad
6914 he had 14 all right good tournament
to the sixty-four of you it games all
alright
you